[Music]
a towering thin creature stalks the
countryside of the janos region in south
america
carrying the bones of his victims in a
sack whistling all the way
vengeful and full of murderous intent if
you hear his whistle it's probably
already too late this terror of the
plane is el silbon or the whistler
and just wait until you hear why this
one time human became the monster he is
now
dr emily zarka and this is monstrum
if you are unfortunate enough to see
elle silbon you'll be looking at an
emaciated figure
more than three meters tall with
elongated limbs and with an old sack
slung over his back
also known as elsin fien the endless
he's a malevolent ghost with a very real
physical presence
the result of being cursed by his
grandfather for killing his own father
he roams the plains of the locianos
region a large area of tropical
grasslands bordered by the andes in the
north and west
and the amazon rainforest in the south
knowing that el sabon is so connected to
that landscape
i wanted to learn more about this south
american boogeyman from someone who had
actually been to the land he haunts so i
contacted
argentinian film director and monster
enthusiast
juan fernandez gebauer who worked on
phantasmagorius
a beautifully and eerily illustrated
series about the myths and legends of
latin america
hi thank you so much for taking the time
to speak with me juan hello doug
it's a pleasure to be in your show i
really like the concert thank you
so what do you know about this monster i
know you spent some time traveling
in colombia el silva is a kind of ghost
or spectre from the area
and he's the soul in pain of a young man
who murdered his father
cursed by this action he wanders the
planes
carrying his father's bones in a sack
and
throwing these gloomy whistles into the
air
which is where his name comes from there
is a phrase i like a lot
that is each era vomits the monsters it
needs
since that first time i heard the legend
of the silvon
many many more times and each narrator
adapts it
a little bit to what they need they are
those who say that
it was rude spoiled boy
he's supposed to have killed his father
because he wanted to eat deer
but his father wasn't able to hunt it
so the boy killed him the version i
heard
says that the father has discovered the
boy with a woman
the family didn't like a prostitute
very angry the father killed her the son
who was madly in love killed his father
in revenge
so the reasons why el sabon is reported
to have killed his father very
to benefit the period and the
storyteller i've also read versions
where elsa bone's father
seduced or assaulted his daughter-in-law
triggering his son's homicidal rage
and in other stories the young man's
father murdered his wife
not because she was a prostitute but
because she was rumored to be
promiscuous
regardless of why the young man killed
his father
all of the stories end one way everyone
agrees that
after seeing the killing the grandfather
of the boy
cursed him forever and he tortured him
with a whip
and then cleaned his wounds with
aguardiente
then he released him to hungry rabbit
dogs
since then els ivonne has been roaming
the roads
and carrying his father remains in the
stag and murdering
drunk people party goers womanizers
and whistling always his melody
el sabon doesn't just wander around
aimlessly
he hunts for womanizers and cheaters
perhaps because of the role
his murderous father and the woman he
loved played in his fate
and he also looks for drunks which might
be because of the alcohol his
grandfather drenched his wounds with
before his death
but no one is safe the occasional
innocent victim may fall into his path
you won't always hear the rattling of
his victim's bones from his sack as he
approaches
but you'll always hear the rise and fall
of his haunting whistle
in this venezuelan story we learn just
how cruel el sabon can be
one night a rancher was hosting a party
a man planned on going but his friends
warned him it was dangerous to walk
through the plains alone
on a dark night like this one but the
man insisted he could protect himself
and set off for the celebration on his
horse the horse ran
fast but upon crossing the stream it
stopped abruptly
the man heard a whistled scale in the
distance as he tried to calm his horse
the whistling was getting closer the
horse spooked and threw the man off
suddenly the whistling faded as if the
whistler were going away
but when the man turned he saw a figure
with painfully thin
elongated limbs so tall he could not see
its face
the figure hit the man with a stick and
even with his machete
the man could not reach the creature to
defend himself
the monster beat the man to the ground
and walked away laughing
the man managed to find his horse and
endured a painful ride to the party
those celebrating asked what had
happened and when he told them
they all crossed themselves the owner of
the ranch told him he had come upon
el silbon and he was a lucky one most of
el saban's victims
do not survive
elsa bone clearly likes to toy with his
prey there's that unusual and creepy
characteristic of his whistle
when you hear it close by that's a sign
you are actually
safe the further away the whistle sounds
the closer to you el sabon really is he
is particularly violent with drunks
sucking out the alcohol from a hole in
their stomachs before removing their
bones from the same
opening he drank from and taking the
bones is the worst part
without them his victims cannot rest
peacefully in death
as they have become part of el sabon's
doomed existence
if you hear elsa bone outside your door
at night and fail to do anything to
drive him away
or if you don't stop to listen to his
whistling a member of your household
will die
a surefire way to drive away his lost
soul is with a dog
since he hates the animals that tore him
apart this is such a
unique and interesting monster what
possibly do you think could have
inspired it
what i found out with elderly people
from the area
is that the legend of sylvan is probably
based in a person called
joaquin flores who probably committed a
crime
similar to this one around 1850
and since an event of this nature is
rare
the people took moral advantage of the
murder
and this story echoed so
that similar events wouldn't happen
again
originally the land of the janos was
populated by nomadic indigenous groups
like the guajibo
by the 19th century when tales of el
silbon took root
many of the land's occupants were cattle
ranchers
livestock was introduced to the janos
region by the spanish colonizers in 1548
and the cattle population rose to an
estimated 4.5
million by the beginning of the 19th
century
this likely explains el saban's
distinctive hat
this style commonly worn by ranchers of
the region
as the cattle population boomed tensions
rose against the spanish occupiers in
the janos region and surrounding areas
the generos a name that appears during
the century to refer to all people who
worked the ranches
joined the revolutionary forces of
simone boulevard in 1818.
as skilled horsemen and fighters they
helped deal the crucial blow to the
spanish crown
in the battle of boyaca following the
deaths in the venezuelan war of
independence and the continued wartime
devastation to crops and livestock
by 1823 only 256 000
cattle remained so monumental changes
occurred when the spanish introduced
cattle to the janos
and when the ranchers of those cattle
contributed to the independence of the
area from spanish rule
this complex history is reflected in the
appearance of the region's most famous
monster
el silbom and the legend and impact
continues
since 1974 an annual venezuelan music
festival
celebrates el sabon and yanero folklore
he has a statue in a venezuelan theme
park
his own horror movies and was even
referenced in a 2003 speech by former
venezuelan president hugo chavez
el silbon has left his impact on popular
culture
but that doesn't mean this monster has
lost his influence in the annos
even young people who sometimes laugh
about it or makes jokes about
the appearance of a silvan when you ask
them seriously
they say they fear him that they can
hear his whistle
at night in the town i believe that
telling the legends
and the tradition of a culture is a way
to preserve an identity
i think it's important to understand
what's cursed us
while it's in the shadow when it's here
today the myth of el silbon is an active
part of the folklore of the janos
continuing a tradition hundreds of years
[Music]
old
you